on va aller plus loin avec nos invités
régis le sommier grand reporter pour rt
france ainsi que claude blanchemaison
qui nous ont rejoints bonsoir à tous les
deux merci d'être avec nous on a vu un
apaisement
comme le disait thomas comme a commencé
à nous le dire thomas sur la forme enfin
quand même avec des petites menaces ça
se finit un petit peu toujours comme ça
régis le sommier joe biden qui donc
brandi la menace dès des sanctions
économiques sur moscou ça avait été
annoncée donc confirmée par joe biden
effectivement que
si en cas d'invasion de l'ukraine par
par l'armée russe et bien les états unis
ray piquerait essentiellement durcissant
les sanctions en s'attaquant
effectivement aux banques aux
possibilités aussi de conversion du
rouble savez dans d'autres monnaies ça
c'est les voiles et les un petit peu là
la palette d'aidés comment des choses
qui vont être qui pourrait être employée
aussi cette éventualité se produisait ce
qui est intéressant quand même on peut
noter cette fois ci c'est qu'il ya quand
même eu concertation la part de joe
biden avec ses alliés c'est parce que
nous avait habitué les états unis
récemment avec leur retrait
d'afghanistan et le fameux contrat de
sous-marins subtilisé au français donc
là il
s'avère que les états unis donc joe
biden a promis d'aborder va appeler
ensuite emmanuel macron angela merkel et
comme
drive in et dry en arrière voilà de
mario draghi donc là il ya une prise en
considération dans le caillou craignent
un avec ont le sens puisque emmanuel
macron aussi réagi là dessus une volonté
aussi de deux d'abord donné que deux 2
comment de temporiser de la part des
français notamment et de revenir à des
formats normandie dans le cadre de deux
donc du coup de rester dans la
diplomatie en tout cas et on sent que ce
coup de fil de joe biden comment avec
eux et vladimir poutine est resté dans
ces cadres qui a pas eu d'escaladé que à
mon avis il ne faut pas attendre à des
excès escalade dans les jours qui
viennent
analystes blanche maison c'est vrai
qu'on a vu deux hommes qui s'étaient
quand même un petit peu invectives et
d'ananas france se souvient quand même
que joe biden avait traité de killer la
dîmière poutine la voilà il était
apparemment content de se voir mais avec
quand même c'est ces mots un petit peu
ferme ça peut faire changer tout même
les choses ont même si on ne connaît pas
encore bien le contenu de cet échange
prestige un petit peu commun genève le
le 16 juin dernier je crois que les deux
chefs d'état veulent parler clair et
parler franc pour essayer d'arriver à
des accords à partir de positions
spontanément très divergentes en juin
ils s'étaient mis d'accord pour créer
deux groupes de travail très important
l'un pour renouer avec les négociations
stratégiques nucléaires puisque c'est
eux qui ont le plus grand stock d'armes
nucléaires et de et de fusées et l'autre
sur les attaques cyber pour justement en
limiter la portée est aujourd'hui en
effet devant les le bruit que font les
tambours de guerre à la frontière
ukrainienne eh bien ils ont probablement
parler clair de la position de l'un et
de l'autre
vladimir poutine il veut deux choses sur
l'ukraine il veut premièrement obtenir
l'autonomie du dombass c'est à dire des
deux provinces de louhansk et la donne
est de l autonomie pour leur profit des
pro russe et puis deuxièmement il veut
il l'a dit la semaine dernière au
kremlin une garantie juridique que
l'otan n'avancera pas en ukraine et
notamment d'un strana n'aura pas
l'installation militaire permanente en
ukraine alors ça c'est deux points
évidemment très très difficile à obtenir
et il est probable que joe biden a a
fait valoir les difficultés qu'il y
avait à obtenir à obtenir les deux
points le premier c'est évidemment dans
un format normandie que ça peut se faire
mais peut-être que pour soi et emmanuel
macron
il faut préciser on le disait tout à
voir aussi registre sonner comme pour le
moment l'europe a quand même été laissés
à l'écart de ces discussions tournant
sur les stratégies qu au mois deux au
mois de juin alors que cela concerne
directement parce que les fusées qui
passe au dessus de sa tête peuvent aussi
tomber en europe et notamment
lorsqu'elles sont de portée
intermédiaire là l'europe n'est pas
tenue à l'écart parce que c'est un
problème européen est effectivement
j'imagine que vladimir poutine a demandé
à bayonne d'essayer de faire pression
sur le président ukrainien pour qu'il
assouplisse sa position sur les
consultations avec les pro-russes de du
dombass de manière à pouvoir y organiser
les élections puisque c'est le point qui
bloque depuis déjà très longtemps on l'a
mise en oeuvre de minsk et que monsieur
ait un ce qui ne veut rien entendre sur
cette affaire et considère que d'abord
il faut qu'il récupère le contrôle de la
frontière avec la russie ce que la
russie n'est pas prêt à lui donner
peut-être un compromis un jour sera d'y
installer des troupes de loi c e on a
sans doute parlé de l'ouest c'est eux on
a sans doute parlé de revoir l'astral
architecture de sécurité de sécurité
européenne puisque l'on fait c'est de ça
dont il a été question pendant les deux
heures de discussions
résistance au mieux ce matin eric
zemmour qui a eu un discours qui est un
petit peu trancher avec le reste c'est
pour ça que ça a attiré mon attention
qui disait george bush père n'a pas tenu
sa promesse de ne pas avancer les pions
avec l'otan en direction de la russie
après la chute du mur de berlin on nous
rappelle le candidat eric zemmour
discours évidemment dissonant
en europe puisque l'europe en général
évidemment reproche à la russie de masse
et ses troupes à la frontière avec
l'ukraine il ya une forme aussi on peut
le voir comme ça de légitimité à vouloir
aussi ne pas se laisser faire et a
défendu du côté russe c'est un discours
qu'on l'entend pas c'est vrai que depuis
la fin de vous avez cités là la chute la
chute du mur hélas la fin de l'urss le
l'otan n'a pas cessé de deux d'engranger
des pays et de l'europe aussi c'était
large il ya une nouvelle réalité
parfois aussi l'existence de l'otan
étaient mises en cause puisque c'est un
c'est un outil qui était utilisée est
justement dans la tactique bloc contre
bloc à l'époque de la guerre froide et
la guerre froide n'étant plus là pas mal
de critiques de l'otan ont dit pourquoi
on continue à avoir cette alliance
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs cette question
est toujours posée puisque on a à chaque
fois qu'il ya une crise ou récemment de
mezel évoqué tout à l'heure le le
problème du traitement des états unis
avec leurs alliés la question de
l'europe de la défense est revenue au
devant de la scène et la question de se
dire comment est ce que l'otan est ce
que l'otan est légitime finalement à
régler alors on sait très bien que à
chaque fois qu'on parle de l'europe de
la défense tout à coup les états unis
brandissent dix ans mais non il y en a
pas besoin donc évidemment que c'est un
outil évidemment ce que dit eric zemmour
est pas entièrement faux sur le fait que
les états unis nous fait cesser de
croire justement cette on imagine quand
ça s'est passé parce que il faut quand
même on parle de guerre froide de
nouvelle guerre froide quand même voir
que les états unis et la russie sont
deux pays qui à cause de ce terme qu'on
a inventé à l'époque ne se sont jamais
affrontées directement tant mieux ç'a
failli arriver quand la russie elle à
l'époque a soutenu cuba et est venu
justement dans le pré carré des états
unis là aujourd'hui ce que disent les
russes c'est que si on accorde justement
l'adhésion si l'ukraine obtient son
adhésion à l'otan est bien l'otan sera
directement sur la frontière de la
russie et donc c'est c'est clairement
dans
une sphère d'influencé russe donc là il
ya une question quand même assez assez
sensible et on peut comprendre la
position des russes sur ce sur ce
dossier avec justement ils ne font
évidemment la crainte d'une escalade que
de blanche maison c'est la ligne rouge
je suis pas sûr je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est l'acte 1 de la révision de
l'architecturé
de l' architecture de sécurité en europe
nous vivons encore sur les schémas de la
guerre froide avec l'organisation de
sécurité de coopération européenne dont
font partie les états unis et la russie
et tous les autres pays européens 57 ans
tous mais aujourd'hui effectivement le
le système à tout a changé puisque un
certain nombre de pays sont sortis de
l'orbité soviétique sont devenus
indépendants et que certains seront très
d'ailleurs dans l'union européenne où le
loup dans l'otan et entre la zone
couverte par l'otan et la russie il
reste une zone intermédiaire l'ukraine
la géorgie et quelques autres pays et il
faut régler en effet le statut de ces
pays et la sécurité dans cette zone
intermédiaire et je crois que c'est ça
que vladimir poutine propose au
président américain mais c'est
évidemment très difficile et ça prendra
beaucoup de temps et ça ne peut pas se
faire sans les européens en tout cas
sans les européens qui comptent comme à
l'époque de la csc eux merci en tout cas
tous les deux clubs en faisant rêver
c'est le sommier de nous avoir apporté
votre analyse après cette rencontre de
près de deux heures entre joe biden et
vladimir poutine cet après midi